chris brockman is your mic on holy holy
god hold on hold on wait wait for it
are we still in there are we on the air
what's that noise i don't know what that
news is
i know you're not a big fan of libation
[Laughter]
we like to drink here
when i sit in for rich because it makes
the show go better well i mean you guys
have had a bar here forever and i don't
know if he even uses it right it was a
fake iced tea we're just doing a like a
a lady who's who lunch three martini
lunch it's just at 10 in the morning
yeah because when i think of ladies the
lunch i think that we are definitely
those two
no that's tj and chris
also to have two women on her radio
television show at the same time is like
this is actually loud i don't think so
they might give us 30 second intervals
my voice is
your voice your voice is uh it's down
horse yeah it's horse how much orange
juice you want in here little splash
not too yeah we'll just go we should you
know a little splash of juice
one part oh geez we can't let the body
be you know
deprived of alcohol for five minutes
you know also tj brought in some
pasteurized juice i said not for kara
henderson snead
it's fresh squeezed
last night too
but i didn't
i think that was right after the ambien
took hold so god knows that i'm lucky to
be here this morning thank you so much
he makes a phenomenal rock win that's
nice you could be a bartender if you
needed this in another career straight
from coffee to alcohol this is the way
this week's gone she makes a good month
oh yeah we have
there we go cheers congratulations on
that
oh i don't know on the super bowl win
wow i mean it's a whirlwind
as you would imagine oh yeah a little
bit
get a little shaky with that it's been a
long week for you henry no it's been
it's been amazing it you know
you always wonder
when you're a reporter you know how does
it feel how does it feel for people when
they actually achieve this thing
that they've been you know thinking
about their entire lives and
you know i mean when you're on the field
after the super bowl i got the chance at
nfl network to cover so many of them and
the worst interviews are the interviews
that you get on the field right after
the super bowl because
people are just shell-shocked
they're shell-shocked they they cannot
process that they are in one of the
great moments
of their lives that they've actually
gotten to the top of the mountain and
it's awesome and the visuals are amazing
but the interviews are terrible right
and so i've always wondered like what
does that feel like and obviously i'm
you know i'm just married into it i'm
i'm not the one that
did anything per se but it's a it's a
really interesting thing it just kind of
washes over you
and it just gets better and better and
better as you continue to process
and you allow yourself to go through
you know a period of time and we've all
seen i'm sure
you know videos of of aaron donald and
to me you know having known him from
when we drafted him to now
it's just like this weight has been
lifted off of him and he is just
fully like complete and he's got a
beautiful family
and he looks great with his shirt off as
we've all seen oh my god i mean come on
and it was it was hilarious when we went
to the parade the other day which by the
way that was his wife erica who was
standing by him which is really
interesting so
um
her dad is um you know he was a coach in
the league forever so aaron donald's
just got this amazing amazing life and
when i got to cal lutheran which is
where the rams facility is
uh the other day when we were going to
take the buses to go then be a part of
the parade
and aaron donald already had his shirt
off at 8 a.m
i'm like we about to get lit this is
going to be so much fun and it was
everything but you just see that
it just washes over people i was joking
i mean a lot of people were talking
about you know less wearing the shirt
with his face on it the other day that
we had given him that had the meme omni
that people have talked about i was
joking with him this morning that i'm
actually wearing a
one with his face on it today because
it's literally i for those listening on
the radio i've just got a big smiley
face sweatshirt on and he has not i mean
he's got this
like cheshire cat kind of grin that he's
had all week long and it is it's just
this
like
like ah like
relief
part of it is i think when you lose one
and you know how awful it is and you
have to wait like the thing about a
season is you know for good or for bad
like you have to like get over it
whether it's a win or a loss and you
gotta go play another game but now when
you don't have another game to play
until september
and so you get to like rest on your
laurels and and you won the last game
it's amazing you don't want to do that
when you lose and you have to sit there
with that loss
for so long so you just felt like
everybody's just got this sense of
completeness which is fantastic that's a
long answer it's a long answer but there
are so many more questions like
we're taught as journalists
to never ask the question how does it
feel and you brought that up that you're
now experiencing how it feels but we are
taught professionally you never ask that
question because it's a lame question
it's not specific you're not garnering
the right answer but
now that you've been able to experience
on both sides
how do you resolve it i mean what is it
like what's it like take us there it's
really interesting to try to you know
if you're if you go into journalism if
you're a reporter like it's it's because
you love to observe people and you love
to be
in situations where you can see them
going through things and and
and really take it in and so
to experience it for myself as well i'm
constantly like
you know vacillating between being
the reporter who's down on the field in
the middle of it
and just you know wanting to document it
and think through a reporter's lens but
then also experience it
for yourself
and
it's it's it's been really fun that way
you know i i tell people all the time
it's a blessing and a curse that i did
what i did for as long as i did because
when les comes home he gets a press
conference every night and i'm not
letting him off the hook right which i'm
sure
a lot of nights he's like can we just
like last question like genuinely he'll
be like
enough
but it also means that i can help you
know in
probably some different ways than than
other people who hadn't been in it but
you do you you know when you see the
people that you love and let's be clear
about this team i know it's the story
and i know it's people what people have
been talking about and it comes across
somewhat
as a platitude but the culture of this
team
and i know i'm a homer is unlike any
other team i've ever been around
it does have shades of what the patriots
were like when i used to cover them
where all of a sudden
this locker room full of these just
great players
took over and created a culture that
became the patriot way and we saw how
that worked out pretty well right and
that is what you've started to see with
this team this was the season
where the players are the ones that took
over and really started taking some of
the mantle so that shawn didn't have to
be
everything
all the time because he is such a big
cult of personality a big part of this
team and why
we won this game but the players kind of
took a lot of that on this year and it
helps when you have
guys like von miller who come in and
they have experienced this before and he
was the one down the stretch and a lot
of you guys out there sports fans have
read about it where vaughn really
challenged aaron donald to be more vocal
to be that vocal leader
because everybody looks over to aaron
and everybody wanted to win this for him
um but when you bring a guy like vaughn
in who's experienced it and says hey
like this is what it takes
to for us to win and i can promise you
it's addictive once you get there you're
not going to want to
you know give it up you're not going to
want to give the trophy up so our
culture and i mean from
our training staff through our personnel
department through our front office
business people it is the most amazing
group of people that every single one of
them when you talk to them after the
game said you know what
i want to win for that person i'm so
happy for you i'm so happy for you and
it was you know i was saying to someone
i said we're
like we're the good guys like we really
like came across that way and that's the
way it feels when you're a part of it
great family men great fathers
it's been a it's just been the pleasure
of my life to be around this group of
people wow wow that's incredible
cara henderson's need in on the rich
eisen show suzy schuster in for my
husband rich
what don't we know the best part of
having you here
is that you get to peel back the curtain
for us yes and you also know what we
want to see right because you've been on
the flip side so
what don't we know golly i mean you
where do you want me to start just give
me any person and i can tell you a story
but here's a good one that
that i you know that really resonated
with me um
obviously odell you know odell has such
a big personality and he is one of the
great characters in our league and i've
seen it even with our kids like he is
just the one they want to
look at be close to and and
man we just got to see just how hard he
worked and
you know so many different parts of of
him you know down the stretch and what a
big part
he was of this team and you see if
you're watching on tv you see a picture
of o'dell with matthew stafford and he's
bawling his eyes out right
and so
when when when he went down in that game
and and all of us his football fans
could see that he was
he was on his way to potentially having
an nvp game he was the one who was able
to
obviously make it so that they couldn't
just focus on cooper cup and
he was such a big part of what we were
able to accomplish down the stretch
which was really a credit to him i mean
to learn our playbook and be able to
operate in our system i mean it's
calculus like you have got to really be
dialed in and he made sure he was so
when he went down
i saw a look on sean's face which when
you know shawn he's very good at kind of
masking you know what's going on but you
could just see that he was you know
devastated it's a look i hadn't seen
since you know cooper cup went down uh
in a game a couple years ago
so les always goes down um into the
locker room at halftime just to kind of
get the vibe be you know listen what's
going what's going on what adjustments
are being made
and he decided
because obviously odell was devastated i
mean he is such an emotional and as his
mom said by the way his mom is just an
absolute badass she is you know track
champion from lsu
cool cool woman
and she was saying to me the other day
she's like he's just so passionate and
you feel it when you're around him and
he was devastated i mean to to have
had the journey he had
to come you know all this way and to
have it go the way it went
and les just decided you know what i'm
gonna stay down in the locker room with
him and just make sure
make sure he's okay obviously he's not
okay but make sure he's doing okay
and really encourage him to go back out
and you said i encouraged him to go back
out because he was such a big part of it
and his being there was going to be
really helpful um for everybody on the
sidelines who was devastated for him so
les stayed down in the locker room and
so he missed the beginning of the second
half so he missed the 75-yard pass and
the turnover and he gets back up you
know into stan cronky's suite where they
were watching the game with his people
and they're trying to tell him about
what happened and he's like i i don't
want to hear it i don't want to hear it
it doesn't matter we just have to you
know move forward
from here but
you know i think it just it it says a
lot about the way that this team
operates like people are in it for each
other and so adele did go back out there
on the field and and you know we saw him
throughout the second half and and you
just felt so much for him and even in
the parade he was on the same bus that
we were
you could feel like he was you know
just somewhat down at the beginning but
then as the day went on when we're
riding through the parade
i mean people are like i mean he is
someone that people are really jacked
about seeing so it was it was really
cool and by the time we got to the stage
at the coliseum he had you know kind of
turned that corner um but it was um you
know that was a that was a cool thing to
hear less talk about like you know
i i needed him to know that he had to be
out there because we were not going to
be especially with the timing of the
robert woods injury we were not going to
be down you know in the super bowl if we
didn't have o'dell to kind of step into
that role sorry my voice is let me take
a little more
little more thank you
that might help you out don't want to be
yeah you want to be part of two parts
cheers
cheers it's a nice one
tell me i i brought the good stuff for
you i wasn't going to bring any crap
no bevmo crap for you i brought the real
deal we've got a little bit of
the code you open the no i opened the
mums first we got boo for the you know
closer
when we talk parade we can go vote okay
uh you mentioned less less snead i don't
know if you know him or not he's your
husband um you mentioned him and when
you think about building a team right
and here you are at the super bowl and
yet you choose to start the third
quarter with your injured player and
that he would lose the ability to watch
so much of it in the moment to be with
the player i think
speaks volumes about who he is as a
person
the architect of the team the decision
maker that he is
it's it's
overwhelming to think about i'm
wondering what might be in your opinion
the biggest misnomer about less that you
hear out there oh well i think you know
greg bishop was on earlier who was the
writer for sports illustrated who wrote
the amazing article that was the story
you know of of how the team um got here
and greg's awesome because he was with
us and you know i was kind of a shadow
writer when we were doing the draft out
of our bunk room in our house during
covid which was hilarious um but i he
you know i think he said it well that
people have a tendency to think because
it's the lazy narrative of the
all-in and the mortgaging or you know
it's it's
if if you
know less he is one of the most process
driven methodical people
that you can meet and process is
everything to him you know he says it
all the time and i'm i'm not sure who
said it originally but you've got to
surrender
you know it probably is john wooden or
someone you've got to surrender the
results to the process and that's what
they did
and this was a methodical i mean
you know i've been
here for 10 years with him
going through this build and when you
think about it you know it's like
you know aaron donald came in at the
towards the beginning johnny hecker was
the first year i was telling him that
the other day he was our you know our
day one guy right like he was in that
he's the one last of the mohicans in
that way like last of the people that
was on that first team but it is such a
methodical
build and so this concept that he's you
know this you know
poker player in vegas that's just
throwing chips around is not true at all
i mean we
in the beginning
we had too many first-round picks right
like we had two first-round picks for
the first couple years because he had
made that big rg3 trade right off the
jump so what he does is really
see where we are in our timeline and
where you are in the build and so when
he made these moves whether it was for
matthew stafford which was incredible
obviously or jaylen ramsey or von miller
or odell
it's because he knows like
we're in this particular window where if
we can get these particular pieces and
put add them to what we already have
then we've got something really special
and they're known commodities you knew
what you were going to get with jalen
ramsey you knew what you were going to
get with von miller we've done enough
research to know what we were going to
get with odell and how passionate he is
about football
and when people come into our building
they know that
you can like
we're not going to micromanage
all these different aspects of your life
we're going to be very very focused
around our football but we're going to
allow you to be you too we're not going
to say hey we want this aspect of you
but if you could leave this other part
of you out that would be great like
that's not who we are we we pull people
in and let them be
who they are and the first thing you
need to know is that when you walk into
our building
like like the first things first it's
football and so people can relax into
that culture so he and sean have really
from the beginning created that and i
think
yet again the long-winded answer to your
question is don't think that he is a
gambler do not think that he's someone
that's just doing something and and
throwing chips around
that's that would be me that's not him
right like he's not that way at all even
on the bus the other day we were joking
everybody was partying on the bus to go
down and les is sitting in the front
seat and i'm like what are you doing up
there like
could you be less fun
and he's like
he's ready to go over the cap.com i'm
like i know come join the party
andrew worth was doing the playlist up
front and and he's like you know i'm the
principal and sometimes like or the the
teacher and the teacher needs to sit in
the front of the bus when the kids go on
the field trip so they can have a fun
time in the back so i'm just gonna sit
up here i feel like that should have
been like a weird motley crew video what
whatever it was remember like rock the
teacher and suddenly the bus goes crazy
unless that's basically what it was i
hope so it was uh yeah we were like we
sent the kids in to the back and
you know it was uh it was it what a
special group of people
i mean what an amazing group of people
that they've assembled
my brother's watching he said great job
keep your questions shorter so i'm going
to keep them shorter
well
he's probably just trying to say tell
her to keep her answers shorter it's
like nine years later nine years later
it's your first mimosa we're just
getting started
wait i have a podcast on podcast one
called just getting started there you go
oh you're nice nicely done that was
accidental hey um who was your biggest
surprise on the rams as you go through
this behind the scenes because really
what we really care about is we want to
know stuff that we
can't know from reading si from watching
tv what have you so who's my biggest
prize what do you mean surprise surprise
surprise
you know
this is this is more personal so i'll
just but i'll but i'll still say it so
when as soon as the clocks hit zero in
the game and it was interesting i mean
you guys were with us you know for the
nfc championship game which was amazing
everybody that was a part of my football
journey and i've known rich and susie
since i was 23 years old at working at
espn as a production assistant so
i had all of you guys who were all part
of our football jour my football journey
in the box so i had you guys and
marshall was in there brenna webb who
was like my best football friend and you
know andrew siciliano who really helped
me through when i chose to retire um
when les all of a sudden made a huge
trade and i'm doing total access and i'm
like yeah i probably can't stay on
total access anymore um but you know
that was emotional for me but as soon as
the clocks hit zero in the super bowl
and i was just kind of excited not
really emotional i turned and i looked
at my son tate who you know really well
and these guys brockman and del tufa met
him when he was like
little person like five years old and
he's been a part of every snap
of every game and he has been the number
one passionate rams fan for since he was
seven years old and he just burst into
tears
and he's gonna kill me if he ever knows
that i'm saying that's because he's 17.
come on mom cringy but
that was the moment for me that was it
surprised me and then i was like of
course
of course he is like what you don't
think what you're bringing your family
through and how emotional it is
for them to be a part of all this
and you know so for me that the greatest
moment it wasn't a surprise but the
greatest moment was when you're on the
field after the game and you see
van jefferson who has to leave to go
you know his wife just went into labor i
had just talked about it with her you
know
two days before and she's like oh i'm
coming to the game and i'm like oh well
you know you might need a ticket you
might need an extra ticket because it
looks like you're going to have a baby
on the spot
um so you see him you see robert woods
and his young daughter on the field and
he said to me you know
having my wife in this little baby gives
me chills
like having them
helped me through
this period of time has meant everything
seeing matthew stafford down there
with his three little girls seeing the
whitworths and their kids are amazing
and what a journey they've all been on
together and so it's the family and and
especially now you know as a wife and
you see the through the lens like we
this team is is pretty young
and so
you see all of these people getting to
go through this with the most important
people in their life like really really
cool
cara henderson snead here on the rich
eisen show suzy schuster in for rich
eisen
you talk about this chemistry yeah of
all these people together
and how it's not artificial how it's
like a real deal chemistry i think
there's so much
preconceived notion about who these guys
are right so
help us understand
what it's like behind the scenes with
angel whitworth and with cooper cup and
eric weddle
and obviously matthew stafford so this
is a this is a great story greg bishop
actually
alluded to it um a little bit earlier
talking about
um you know a group of people at nobu
right so
i get a call and it's the
tuesday
after the
nfc championship game and it's the
players day off and it's really their
last you know day off but they were like
you know what we're gonna take the day
off
because
we don't need to get dialed in 10 days
or however long before the super bowl
we're going to do that
you know when we get dialed in we're
going to be dialed in and so melissa
whitworth who is hilarious like maybe
one of my favorite people of all time
were very close
she called me she was like what are you
doing and i'm like what do you mean i'm
like i'm i'm driving just my you know my
kid to school and she's like meet us at
nobu at five
and i'm like okay she's like just trust
me meet us at nobu at five i'm like okay
and she's like and i've already told les
and i told him he's coming he doesn't
have an option meet us at nobu at five
and i'm like i'm in like la
like you know gear i got my sweatshirt
and she's like so are we we've been out
since 10 this morning me to sit no move
at five okay so we show up at nobu
and it just it was the whitworths
and the cups drove up right behind us
cooper and his wife anna who is amazing
and
the staffords and us and so we we the
eight of us
just sit down to have dinner at nobu and
i you know had the chance to cover
matthew stafford a lot
when um when i was a reporter and and so
i met him you know at his locker so you
know what that's like you know you're
only getting part of somebody
and i've heard obviously
over the last year all these amazing
things about him but because of kovid
like i hadn't had the chance to really
be around any of the players
over the last year and so and they were
very good about keeping everybody
separated so this was the first time
that i had i'd met his wife and got to
go to a game with her
um she's hilarious and awesome but i'd
never met him
as just a person
and
i sat there and i was talking to him
about a variety of things
and i was like i get it
i get it he is the most laid-back easy
going
like fun to be around but just like
easy person i've ever met and
you know so we're all sitting there and
he looks at me and he goes i'm really
embarrassed
i said wise like
we went out this morning for breakfast
we didn't think we were just going to be
hanging out all day we thought we were
just gonna get a cup of coffee and a
donut and here we are
sitting in the nicest restaurant you
know in malibu and he's like and i'm in
like like a just a raggedy like hooded
sweatshirt and i was like oh honey
malibu oh swedish like this is la like
you've got to understand something like
if you can show up at nobu and end up in
the bet at the best table in in the
building for eight people
and you can have a hooded sweatshirt on
that's when you know
you've gotten somewhere in la because
last we were there one night and it may
have been the night we were with you and
rich and we look over and there's bill
gates yep and he's got a hoodie on i
said bill gates had a hoodie on here i
think you're gonna be just fine but that
tells you something about him too like
they're all he's just and you looked
around and all the women at this table
are very alpha i mean i'm probably like
the alphalite of the group i mean anna
is fierce she's hilarious and awesome
she was a track star at arkansas before
she went back and and you know went to
help cooper knowing what he was going to
be melissa whitworth is a force in
nature
and
so fun very louisiana she was miss
louisiana and she is would be right here
with us having a cocktail and kelly
stafford i mean if you don't know about
kelly stafford you haven't been paying
attention and she is just you know
amazing and and fun and
you know bold and just will
give zero
whatevers you know like she will come
after you if she wants to and so you've
got these alpha women and then you look
around the table at the men and they're
just all these very
kind of humble
low-key
competent
you know
confident guys and i'm like i get it i
get it
does that make sense it's like
all these alpha women and all of these
just like laid back like you know guys
and it's a great it's a great mix i
think you know this better than anyone
if you cover sports and it really
varies per sport
very much so in football
because it's a once a week game and
because of the nature of the teams
the women provide
the ability for the guys to go out to
their practice go on the road it's very
different than basketball or then
baseball i don't know as much about
hockey i mean i've covered five hockey
games in my life but i know that for
football
it's that basis of it's
oftentimes that group of women
that provides that ability there's no
doubt and it's um
you know it's a it's a i mean obviously
i we went to seattle for a game and i
went with anna melissa and kelly and it
was the first time i'd met kelly it's
actually very funny she told the story
on her podcast we were all flying up
together and you know when she came on
the plane she didn't realize who i was
and matthew was mortified by this story
because she had no idea i mean she just
was coming in you know at the last
second she's got three young kids so i'm
sure she was like all of us like coming
in on two wheels
and so she got on the plane and we all
start talking about
you know football and the rams and i go
to use the restroom and she turns to mel
and she goes man
your friend knows a lot about the rams
right i'm like talking about well you
know the second cornerback and the
dignity then you know the special teams
guys and she's like i mean she's really
dialed in on the rams and she's like
that's les wife and you know and she was
mortified it was funny but
but you when i went to a game with those
guys and we were sitting in the stands
in seattle and that's when i was like
okay i'm never going to do that again
because we're lucky that
we got out of there without me throwing
hands right like you just get real
like you get emotional and these are
your people out there and people are
talking about him i'm like i don't need
to do that again um
but you saw them go through
i mean it's one thing i mean yes you
know it's my my husband's built the team
blah blah blah but
when these are their people out there
putting their bodies on the line and
i just got such a different appreciation
for
how stressful that is
and that's i think the difference in
football it's it's such a physical thing
so they have to be so many different
things they've got to be the ceo of
whitworth incorporated they've got to be
then you know kelly's a registered nurse
so i'm sure that has come into play many
many times i mean matthew's the toughest
player i've been around in recent years
and so you have to be so many different
things and it's so taxing
physically mentally emotionally so you
know the women
of the group
really do play such a huge role
in the success
of a team
we're going to start looking at behind
the scenes photos from the parade oh
good stuff
and the question of course is what's it
like when it becomes personal because
you've covered these parades it's so
different when you're covering the
parade but when you care about it i
can't even imagine well you know it's
fun
i we decided we were like you know what
like
there are parade rules which are
basically like there are no rules right
like if you're gonna be in a super bowl
parade like any normal thing is just
throw it out the window so you know the
the meme that's been making its rounds
of of less with the you know well for
lack of a better way of putting it screw
them picks yeah thing which people
actually think he said which of course
he didn't say right there it is so
he actually decided he was going to wear
that for the parade yeah which is real
decisions i know a guy named rich eisen
who likes to wear that's what i was
laughing earlier when i saw rich wear
the shirt with his with his own you know
little avatar on it but so not less to
wear like you know less well like so not
like him to wear that so that's what we
were like this is hilarious you've got
to do that i mean if you're ever going
to wear that shirt hilarious it's today
how's the day right it's parade rules
like you can wear that in the crowd
obviously he was doing it because he
knew the crowd and the fans have been so
into it and of course there you know
there was a nice chant that had emanated
along the way
and so it was really cool and i know
everybody wants to show pictures of a
particular spot on a particular street
and whatever whatever and we aren't that
many fans well the reason was when we
started at the edge of usc you know
there were fans and then it build it was
building and building and building as we
went and all the fans that were at the
beginning of the parade because it's
slow enough it wasn't like that great
shot that they had of the braves bus
that went like 40 miles an hour past the
fans
like we were obviously going slowly so
all those people were running too and
they were in and so as you were going
through the parade route
the noise started i'm getting chills
thinking about it and then it just built
into this kind of like deafening roar by
the time you got towards the end that
was just constant and we're all looking
at each other like this is like
it's just such a like awesome experience
and you see these fans and some of them
you even recognize whether it's from
you know twitter and communicating with
them on twitter or you've seen them at
games or they're the big fans and you
can see you know you can pick certain
people out of the crowd and kind of let
them know that like you see them
that's what i was saying the last like
oh look at that guy i i told you about
this guy there he is there's that guy
and you're you're specifically and
there's the you know we were on a camp
college campus so the kids are hanging
off the balconies
it was so much fun and you know the joy
that you saw
in the players to just be able to
you know let the steam off but then also
like our bus oh in this great picture
this is odell cooper van jefferson for
those who um are not watching right like
these guys had such a good time together
but then also like
all the personnel guys were on our bus
right like these are the guys who are
the scouts who are the behind the scenes
guys and as one of one of our you know
main logistics um
people was saying they were like oh the
personnel bus had a vibe the personnel
bus had a real vibe and it was great and
this is this is chris schuler right like
this is the grandson of don schula who's
one of our linebackers coach and he had
a full cooler like people were showing
up at the facility with i'm like with
like massive suitcases full of like
champagne and
and behind him this is great so behind
him is odell's mom with a backwards hat
that's odell's girlfriend who is going
to we were worried this is funny she's
very pregnant she's very pregnant as
well like we we were worried on the bus
on the way there they were on our bus
andrew whitworth and i were joking i
said okay let's youtube how to deliver a
baby
and if oh god
if it does happen
if it does happen here's what's going to
happen andrew you are you're the person
like he's just got that i've got this
thing about him you're delivering the
baby i said cooper's catching it
and you know
you know it is kelly's going to be the
nurse
i'm just going to be there just to you
know you know read the instructions or
off of youtube
but um well you could call it you could
actually do that no no no no
if you want it i'm good with that but
like no adele's about to have his baby
soon too so you see in all these
pictures just that the mixture of people
right and so it was
it was that it was
it was pure joy
it was pure joy and aaron donald
he is such a great guy he's such a great
dad
such a great player
such a great leader in the team and this
is like i was saying when you see aaron
donald with his shirt off
you know it's going to be fun right like
this is
crash have it on aaron donald's yeah
have it on aaron donald so he was so
happy and you know unless that he he
came in and hugged him there's a great
shot i have it's it's my favorite
picture that i got which was you know
aaron and les
and matthew stafford and they were all
together and i just managed to get there
right when you know they were all three
together
and aaron has this look on his face and
he had said to les like
thank you like you changed my life right
you changed my life
and les is like uh
you you changed mine too right i mean
come on
how could you ever
like do this without an aaron donald on
your team he's just the best he's just
the best
so great great great day and to be able
to have it with your kids too
it's
it's pretty great and then you told les
to go home and make the bed uh he does
he's never a dishes guy yeah he's a real
good dishes guy like you know the bed's
not really his his thing but he does
like he does like doing the dishes i'm
sure rich does too oh yeah it's great
just is just as methodical back on
peacock i'm susie schuster and for rich
eisen kara henderson sneed in for all
hour here hour number two of the rich
eisen show because we needed some behind
the scenes
of rams victory
2022. we've got mimosas we've got a
little shampoo
to crack our second bottle here we go
hoskins take me in three three who's
house
[Applause]
you know it's funny it's a celebration
when i hear i love l.a the iconic song
because of my experience it's a laker
song right because i i i literally hear
that and i think of shaq and kobe the
three-peat the second time around what
have you
and you got to have it with the rams
i know i think it's um
it's really fun to be a part of you know
a big city
championship and and
obviously i mean all the all the team
well
all the teams have had a lot of success
recently here so it's fun to be a part
of that right like to feel like
okay we're giving you know and
you saw if you saw aaron donald on the
james corden show i'm sorry if i'm
dropping another show and i'm not
supposed to do that but
he was unbelievably
great on that but you could tell how
much it meant to him
to win
for the city and to get like the key to
the city and like for him to like
for you to feel like you're delivering
something to these fans
which as the guys were talking about you
know my twitter account
and i was able to give some tickets away
to nfc championship game but like it's
been the joy of my last two weeks
really like communicating with all our
rabid fans on twitter
and if you my i'm at kara henderson on
twitter if you want to see some of the
funniest celebration videos from winning
the super bowl go and just scroll
through and i would just sit there for
like the other and i was there for like
two hours just going through all of
these people's celebration videos and
every time we
every time aaron donald sacked joe
burrow it's like you had that same
feeling over and over again but you got
it from
different perspectives in the stadium
different people's you know garages big
parties small you know this one guy his
two young kids were asleep upstairs so
he was trying to celebrate but do it as
like a silent film almost it was
hilarious so
that's it like when you get to meet the
real rabid rams fans
and and know that they've been fans
through
our move to st louis and back and
deliver this to them
it's awesome it really is you know you
mentioned l.a in the parades a lot was
said about lebron saying he wanted to be
a part of the parade now it's been since
2017. it's been a minute
so you can't really jump on the parade
bandwagon if you're uh i think the
statue of limitations should probably be
i don't know a year or two maybe if it's
during covid what have you but you can't
just drop back into the parade route
i mean lebron's had many many parades
let us have our first parade first right
we
we've never been in a parade before but
you have now karen henderson snead here
on the rich eisen show welcome back to
all of you listening on the radio those
of you watching on peacock however
you're taking in this rich eisen show
thank you
uh a virtual mimosa to you on this
mimosa friday so happy to have you
joining us here in any way that you can
back to the parade i've been able to
have at least one drink for every
listener watcher out there over the last
two weeks
that's my that's my service to the
community and as well you should you've
been near nearly sober for a moment
since you guys won and i can say that
it's so funny since you guys
won the super bowl i i am just along for
the ride literally probably good that
i'm not driving um
no but seriously it's uh it's
you do feel a part of it and you know
you you as a as a family member you go
through so much
you go through so much to get here
i mean i when we i mean the year that i
went back to nfl network and was went
back as an executive and and then i left
again it was because i was like okay
i don't know what's going to happen next
i mean we started out three and one we
ended up going four and 12.
does les get fired there's a
very distinct possibility he could i'm
not you know naive i'm like i cover
football for a living like a lot of four
and 12 gm's get fired
and then they had the wherewithal to go
and hire sean and
so you know when you go through the the
roller coaster that is the nfl and then
you finally get to push it all the way
to the top and
and sit there for a minute
it you really do it you you sit there
and think about all those years and all
of those things
that took getting there and it's um
it does it continues to like you process
it and it washes over you more and more
as you go what don't we know about sean
mcvay
oh man i i love that human being so much
i you know i'll never forget
when les came home and said i really
think we're going to hire the 30 year
old right because
it was at the point where it was like
people are like they're interviewing a
30 year old to be the head coach and
he's like and i was like you've got to
be kidding me come on
no well i mean i i've got jeans older
than him right like genuinely that old
trope so
but i went and he's like
you've got to come and meet him
and he's like marshall's going to be
there so marshall fox obviously we're
all very close with marshall as well
and i was like okay wait a minute if
marshall is giving this guy the thumbs
up
i've been around marshall enough to know
that he's you know
he does not suffer fools he does not
suffer people that don't know what
they're talking about if he gives him a
thumbs up and i met sean and within 10
seconds i just looked at less and it was
like i get it
he is um this rare
combination it's not rare it's unique he
is the unique combination
of a people person who genuinely meets
every single player in that organization
where they are
and tries to make them the best versions
of themselves not what he wants them to
be the best versions of themselves
so there's that and he cares so deeply
about each and every one of them he's an
emotionally like
such an empathetic human being
and so
you have that
and then you have the most brilliant
football mind that you could ever talk
to anytime i'm talking to him about
football i feel like i'm talking to
somebody who's splitting the atom and
i'm back in basic math and i feel like i
know a lot a lot about football but i
mean you get to talking to him and
you're like oh this is
this is rare so all of us have met
people who are really brilliant
tacticians in football they have a
tendency to be a little bit more wonky
and a little less people driven and very
you know
you know mad professor types
he's got both things in spades
and so
you you just love the fact that he can i
mean
he can do both things
which is so rare and which is why our
team has the personality
and the success that they that they've
had i can say this to you because you're
a journalist we've got a minute to a
heart out i feel it's really nice
i got a minute so i want to hear in a
minute what are your thoughts on next
year because obviously you can't share
bedroom secrets but i want to know what
you think about what it looks like for
this team well i think
i think this i think whatever
people may have been thinking about
before
we won
when you went with a group of people
like this and you heard people say at
the parade you heard them like
you heard aaron donald say if you can
get this group of people back together
like
without the pressure of having to go win
a super bowl but the possibility of it
i think it's i i think
i think it's a distinct possibility that
you end up with this same group of
people back together i hope so
i hope so you heard it here
much more when we come back
so let me explain for all of you on
peacock the nature of this relationship
so we've known each other since we were
23 years old and worked in bristol
connecticut rich was a budding sports
center anchor
you said budding did you see where she
said budding there that was great no i
didn't mean that he was a little uh
chunky charlie did i say that i didn't
say that did i buddy believe me after
these two weeks i'm not calling anybody
chunky charlie
which was this
terubic looking sports in her anchor
wow
i don't think i'm selling anybody down
the river that i don't sell down the
river seven days a week no
cara's hiding under underneath the hat
okay fine shall i set the table the two
of us are in bristol
we would walk by each other in the
hallways
bristol was a tough place back then well
let's be clear like i was like you know
probably in some baggy jeans and
whatever and
susie was i don't like the way she was
like no no i mean it like you were just
like fierce she was like strolling by in
her black pants and she was like going
somewhere
dressed for the job you wanted not the
job i was just try i was just trying to
get through the day that being said
she and rich were best friends and still
are best friends to this day how many
years later how old are we well 25 years
later right so anyway 25 years later to
make a long story short
she meets less
less and i get each other like rich and
i get each other too
a lot of bertie higgins singing in their
kitchen
so here's what happens
in case those are wondering these two
knuckleheads get together we are
knuckleheads second third fourth glass
of whatever
the karaoke happens
or it's just a background of sonos and
they're like yeah i don't know and then
they just started singing last night
look at each other like can we go to bed
now like yeah you guys are eating kale
over in the corner and and rich and i
are like on our ninth bottle of rose and
often times when i was traveling for abc
sports people would say oh i saw you out
with rich last week i'm like no that was
kara
i'm sorry that they they thought that
because i'm sure we were like you know
doing something somewhere you know susie
it might be a good time i don't know if
we have enough time a few months ago
rich had brought up something and he
said next time susie's here ask her
about the ultimatum and he refused to
tell us and he said when you're here so
i don't know
i don't know if we have enough time with
character and chair maybe she can stay
till the next 30 seconds wait wait mike
hoskins just said 30 seconds 29 28.
let's see
shaquille o'neal when we come back as
well as amy
thank you cara
thank you for having me hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here